in other equally depressing news this
week and we're still so very early in
the week and that's what makes it even
more depressing Ford Motor Company
announced that they were going to be
laying off thousands of workers 7,000 to
be exact
7,000 Ford employees salaried
white-collar Ford employees people
making good wages with good benefits had
good jobs 7,000 are being laid off 900
alone just this week 500 of those here
in the United States the remainder
working for Ford overseas so not all
7,000 I guess are coming from the United
States so I I guess that's a plus right
but I think Bernie Sanders actually did
the best job of summing up why this is
such a disgusting story this is what
Bernie tweeted on Monday after Ford made
this announcement he said Ford got
nearly 750 million in tax breaks from
the Trump tax scam and paid at CEO 18
million last year now Ford is laying off
thousands of workers the bottom line
Republicans sold the tax scam as a way
to create jobs and help workers they
lied and that's 100% correct because
Ford is estimated that this is going to
save them 600 million ish a year maybe
650 million a year yeah but you already
got 750 million in tax breaks from the
Republican Party so even pocketing an
extra seven hundred and fifty million
dollars a year wasn't good enough for
you you want to save an extra 650
million a year so that you can bring
your total savings to one point four
billion dollars a year by laying off
people by destroying American jobs by
ruining households by kicking their
top-earning around into the street
that's what's happening to the men and
women at Ford and it's happening to 500
of them by Friday of this week and
Bernie's also right in the fact that
Republicans promised us corporations
were going to save money
but that money was going to go back and
it was going to create jobs they were
going to invest in their own companies
they were going to expand they were
gonna give you better benefits they were
going to give you bonuses remember that
all the hype around the few
companies they gave a handful of their
employees a thousand dollars at the end
of that year right after the tax scam
passed those bonuses didn't come back
this past year in corporations admitted
that they weren't gonna come back ever
those were one-time it was basically a
publicity stunt and it worked oh and
also fewer than 13% of the companies who
got the Donald Trump Republican tax scam
cut only 13% actually spent it on their
businesses the rest of the money went to
shareholder dividends and buying back
their own stock which stock buybacks are
also at an all-time high
and that's because of the Republican tax
scam they don't care about expanding
their businesses they are already most
of them the size that they want to be
what they care about if they're gonna
invest in their own company is
automation how do we get rid of the
human beings and replace them with a
machine that is happening here happens
with automotive companies like Ford
especially but the bottom line is that
we were lied to a majority of people in
this country do understand that there's
very few people out there today in the
you know middle class or the working
class or the the underclass who say that
no this tax scam was a good idea even
Republicans who are in those
demographics say that no it was a lie
we're not gonna get anything nobody buys
trickle-down anymore except of course
for the top one percent and corporations
because they're the only ones who
benefit from it unfortunately a lot of
members of Congress happen to be in the
top 1% so they all benefited from their
own tax cut package in fact one of them
the congressman from Florida whose name
escapes me at the moment the day after
the day excuse me that he voted for the
tax cut package after he cast his vote
he then left Congress and went and
closed on a new yacht and the yacht
happened to be in the same value that he
was expected to save under the new tax
bill that's what this was about putting
more money in the pockets of rich people
putting more money into the bank
accounts afford not caring one bit
whether or not they actually spent that
money on their
employees where if they kept the jobs
that they already had or if they even
shipped them overseas they didn't care
and that's another things that Trump
promised us multiple times throughout
his presidency that he was going to make
Ford keep their jobs here in the United
States remember he said it was gonna
happen forward was gonna happen with
carrier pretty much it was gonna happen
with Foxconn in Wisconsin bringing all
these new jobs in everything Donald
Trump has touted of creating jobs or
keeping jobs here in the United States
has been an absolute lie but instead of
saying aw crud I'm really horrible at
negotiating with these country companies
what did he do yesterday after Ford made
this announcement he headed to
Pennsylvania to give another one of his
hate-filled rallies where at some point
they were once again chanting lock her
up can you imagine can you imagine being
obsessed with Hillary Clinton that much
here in 2019 in May of 2019 still being
obsessed with Hillary Clinton I didn't
even care which side of the aisle you're
on obsessed with Hillary Clinton needs
to go away now but nonetheless he wasn't
out there saying that oh we do have a
problem companies are cutting jobs and
I'm gonna have to get tough with him no
he went into his usual talking points
about how great everything is how much
he's kicking China's butt in the trade
war you know how stupid the Democrats
are how fake the news is he didn't talk
about the fact that everything is a lie
the economy is not doing great it looks
great on paper but when you actually go
out there and you start to look at it
when you read the labor reports which I
hate to admit that I actually have done
it's boring it's tedious but they do not
paint a picture of a rosy economy we're
not adding jobs that actually matter in
fact as Ford pointed out this week we're
losing those good jobs and replacing
them with minimum wage seasonal or
temporary workers the economy is not
doing great but Donald Trump would
rather continue whistling past the
graveyard pretending that he's the great
economic savior of the United States and
unfortunately too many people who show
up to those Magal e's actually believe
that